María quiere comprar un auto nuevo.
El vendedor de autos le dice que, el auto que ella quiere,
tiene un consumo estimado de gasolina
de 24 kilómetros por galón.
El autio tiene un tanque de 12 galones.
María le dice a su amiga que el auto recorrerá exactamente 288 kilómetros con un tanque lleno.
¿Esta afirmación es razonable o no?
¿por qué sí o por qué no?
Los invito a que pausen el video y analicen
cada una de las opciones con cuidado.
Ahora veamos cada una de ellas.
La primera opción.
Sí, la justificación es que, el auto puede
viajar 24 km por galón
por 12 galones del tanque igual
a 288 km con un tanque.
La matemática se ve bien ya que estos galones...
ya que estos galones se van con estos de acá
y nos quedan las unidades de km, 24 por 12
es 288, la matemática aquí luce bien,
pero esta afirmación que ella hace de que el auto recorrerá exactamente 288 kilómetros
con un tanque lleno, en esta afirmación ella
asume que el auto viaja exactamente 24 km por galón,
lo que es muy diferente a lo que nos dice el vendedor,
que esto tiene un consumo estimado de gasolina,
no es un consumo exacto.
El estimado pudo ser un redondeado de cuando
el auto fue probado, pudo haber llegado a
23.6 km por galón o incluso a 24.4 km por
galón, los cuales son una gran diferencia,
por lo que no tendremos exactamente 288 kilómetros.
Otra cosa es que este estimado pudo salir
de promediar muchos viajes de muchos kilómetros
en diferentes condiciones, por ejemplo, usa
menos gasolina si se viaja cuesta abajo
o en una autopista, se usa más gasolina cuando
estamos en el tráfico o si vamos cuesta arriba
o si vamos contra un viento más fuerte, así
que no podemos asegurar que se pueda recorrer
exactamente 288 kilómetros sin saber exactamente
cómo se tomó esta medida.
El octanaje del combustible también será
un poco diferente, por eso es difícil afirmar
que se viajará exactamente 24 kilómetros
por galón, el vendedor solo dio un estimado,
así que ésta no es.
Opción B.
Sí.
El consumo estimado de gasolina puede usarse
para calcular la distancia exacta
que puede viajar el auto con un tanque lleno.
Ya mencionamos que esto es un estimado, es un aproximado de lo que el auto puede viajar
con un tanque, pero no da la distancia exacta,
así que la opción B tampoco es.
Opción C.
No. 24 kilómetros por galón es un estimado,
un redondeo al entero más cercano,
por lo que no es razonable tratar de calcular la
distancia exacta que puede recorrer el auto.
Justo lo que hemos venido diciendo, es un
estimado que probablemente es un redondeo
y no es razonable usarlo para
calcular distancias exactas.
D.
No.
La distancia que el auto recorre se calcula
dividiendo 24 kilómetros entre 12 galones,
24/12 queda exactamente 2 y no 288.
Bueno, ésta es la peor respuesta de todas,
todo esto está mal,
así que la respuesta correcta es C.